[Music]
[Music]
wow jesus what the hell man still in
control no overwhelming feelings of rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to gen 4 when you sleep was the air
horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
yeah who's your best friend nikki
spandex spandex is your best friend
being a hulk asks for balance
you have so much more to learn
yes
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
if you want to go back to life as a
lawyer i i respect that
he doesn't mean that
more and more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for
them and i want the she-hulk to be the
face of
jennifer wallace
namaste
i have a serious conflict of interest
this man tried to kill my cousin bruce
yeah that's quite all right oh
people only care because i'm
representing emil blonsky i think they
care cause they're like hey that girl's
green
do your thing god i really like this
outfit
i'm not proud of this
miss walters we answered to a higher
power our universe is on the edge of a
precipice
i am a lawyer
we do things by the book
the book of the shanty no the book of
american
uh laws
[Music]
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero
let's do this
you know that friend you had in high
school
who was way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
i think i'm jealous is that what i'm
feeling
[Music]
being a superhero
is a trial by fire who's gonna protect
the world it's not people like you
[Applause]
i'm jennifer walters i'm a lawyer i have
great friends can we get some shots
please it's an emergency a demanding job
we just started a superhuman law
division and i want you to be the face
of it
and a frustrating family because we
didn't ask for this
but you still gotta deal with it your
transformations are triggered by anger
and fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing
oh
it feels like if i don't transform i'm
gonna die
yes yes yes
no
no
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer can you tell us where she-hulk is
jen you're a story now
girl your ass looks crazy right now
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
is there anything more depressing than
dating in your 30s yeah this is the best
that i've had in a while
oh should we split some fries let's get
those to go
[Music]
you